>>> TONIGHT, A VERDICT FOR THE
FALLING CRYPT TOE KING, SAM
BANKMAN-FRIED, THE 31-YEAR-OLD
FOUNDER OF FTX HAS NOW BEEN
FOUND GUILTY ON ALL 7 COUNTS OF
FRAUD AND CONSPIRACY.  NOW,
CONVICTED OF STEELING BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS FROM HIS OWN CRYPTO
CURRENCY CUSTOMERS.  ONE OF THE
BIGGEST WHITE COLOR CRIME THAT
IS WE'VE SEEN SINCE BERNIE
MADOFF WAS SENT TO PRISON.  HOW
LONG DID THE JURY DELIBERATE
BEFORE THE VERDICT TONIGHT?
>> Reporter: KAITLIN, THEY
DELIBERATED FOR FOUR HOURS.
CONVICTED ON ALL CUBITIS
INCLUDING WIRE FRAUD, SECURITIES
FRAUD, AND COMMODITIES FRAUD.
ANYONE WATCHING THE TRIAL REALLY
NOT SURPRISED OF THE OUTCOME,
GIVEN THE OVERWHELMING AMOUNT OF
EVIDENCE THAT PROSECUTORS
PRESENTED DURING THE COURSE OF
THE TRIAL INCLUDING FINANCIAL
DOCUMENTS SHOWING FAKE BALANCE
SHEETS SHOWING THAT THEY WERE
TRYING TO SHOW THAT THEY HAD
MORE MONEY THAN THEY DID.
INCRIMINATING CONVERSATIONS
BETWEEN BANKMAN-FRIED AND SOME
OF HIS FORMER EXECUTIVES, AND
TESTIMONY FROM HIS FORMER
EXECUTIVES SAYING HE VERY WELL
KNEW THAT HE WAS STEALING
INTEREST HIS CUSTOMERS AND USING
THAT MONEY FOR WHATEVER ELSE HE
WANTED.  THROUGHOUT THE IT TRIAL
PROSECUTORS PORTRAYED THIS MAN
AS SOMEONE OBSESSED WITH GREED,
SOMEONE WHO WAS OVERLY AMBITIOUS
AND A MAN WHO THOUGHT HE COULD
BYE-BYE PRESIDENT ONE DAY.  HE
SEE CREATLY USED THIS FTX, AND
SECRETLY USED CUSTOMER'S MONEY
FOR WHATEVER HE WANTED T. COULD
HAVE BEEN TO CONTRIBUTE TO A
POLITICAL CAMPAIGN, TO BUY
PROPERTY, OR, AS THEY ALSO SAID
TO REALLY PROP UP ALAMEDA
RESEARCH THIS TRADING BUSINESS
THAT HE HAD FOUNDED WHICH WAS
FINANCIALLY.  ONE OF THE STAR
WITNESSES THAT COURT WATCHERS
SAW DURING THE COURSE OF THE
TRIAL, HIS EX-GIRLFRIEND,
CAROLYN HE WILLSON, A FORMER
CEO, AND SHE SAID THAT HE VERY
WELL KNEW HE WAS STEALING MONEY
FROM CUSTOMERS, FUNNELING IT TO
OTHER PLACES, SHE SAID THEY LIED
TO INVESTORS AND AUDITORS, AND
OF COURSE, THE MAN TESTIFIED
HIMSELF, BANKMAN-FRIED TESTIFY
ADD AND SHOWING HIMSELF AS
SOMEONE TRYING TO MAKE AS MUCH
MONEY AS POSSIBLE AND GIVE AS
MUCH MONEY AWAY TO GOOD CAUSE.
BUT, HE REALLY DIDN'T DO HIMSELF
ANY FAVORS BECAUSE ON CROSS
EXAMINATION WHEN HE WAS ASKED
OVER AND OVER ABOUT SPECIFIC
DETAILS ABOUT HIS BUSINESS, HE
SAID "I CAN'T RECALL OR I CAN'T
REMEMBER" HE SAID THAT MORE THAN
ONE HUNDRED TIMES, JURORS DIDN'T
BUY IT, KAITLIN.  AT THE END OF
THE DAY, $8 BILLION GONE, LOST,
MONEY THAT PEOPLE HAD FOR
INVESTMENT, MONEY THAT PEOPLE
WERE GOING TO USE FOR SAVINGS,
ALL OF THAT MONEY GONE,
PROSECUTORS SAY BECAUSE OF THIS
MAN'S GREED.  THE U.S. ATTORNEY
CAME OUTSIDE COURT JUST TONIGHT
AND SAID THE FOLLOWING, THE
GOVERNMENT HAS NO PATIENCE FOR
FRAUD AND CORRUPTION, HE WILL BE
SENTENCED ON MARCH 28TH.
>>> AND JASON, JUST BEFORE YOU
GO, GIVEN HE WAS AT THE TOP, I
MEAN, HE WAS THE PINNACLE OF
CRYPTOCURRENCY, WHAT WAS HIS
REACTION IN COURT TODAY WHEN
THEY READ THAT GUILTY VERDICT?
>> Reporter: WELL, HE WAS
CLEARLY NERVOUS, BEFORE, EARLIER
DURING THE EVENING WHEN HE WAS
STANDING IN FRONT OF THE COURT,
HE WAS TAPPING HIS FOOT.  AND A
NUMBER OF COURT OBSERVERS,
AGAIN, NO SURPRISE HERE, GIVEN
THE OVERWHELMING AMOUNT OF
EVIDENCE THAT WAS PRESENTED
HERE, AND EVERYONE WAS
WONDERING, WHAT COULD POSSIBLY
BE THE DEFENSE HERE, AND AGAIN,
AT ONE POINT, THE DEFENSE SAID
HE TOLD JURORS IF A MISTAKE WAS
MADE, IT DOESN'T MEAN IT WAS A
CRIME.  IT WAS CLEAR THAT HE WAS